je suis pas fière seulement je suis très
heureuse de vous accueillir ce soir
heureuse parce que en fait
l'inauguration de ce Phénix c'est plutôt
une bonne nouvelle à
Chanteloup-les-Vignes l'heure est à la
fête trois ans après l'incendie criminel
qu'il avait ravagé le chapiteau renait
de ses cendres son nom est tout trouvé
le phénix
[Musique]
ce cirque qui abritait une troupe de
théâtre se métamorphose en centre
artistique et numérique un véritable
symbole de célébration de la culture
pour la ville ça sera à la fois une
salle de cinéma ça sera la fois un
théâtre ça sera le lieu de la danse au
lieu de la musique le lieu du hip-hop le
lieu de ce qu'on veut parce que l'idée
c'est qu'on nous surprenne et que les
habitants se lavent la propriétaire
qu'en fait ils sont en capacité
d'inventer des formes nouvelles de
culture il aura fallu plus de 18 mois de
travaux pour ériger l'équipement de 650
mètres carrés les architectes se sont
inspirés des carrières souterraines de
gypse très présentes dans la région
pendant l'Antiquité on a voulu que cet
équipement reprenne cette forme
finalement de grandes grottes publiques
qui vient des sols et pour faire son
intérieur et donc le effectivement se
déploie comme ça en grande compte qui
après va nous servir pour faire le
travail acoustique à l'intérieur du
bâtiment pour en faire une salle de
spectacle la ville de
Chanteloup-les-Vignes a pu compter sur
de nombreux soutiens dont la région
Île-de-France est le département des
Yvelines dès le lendemains de l'incendie
nous sommes venus pour annoncer que nous
financerions 100% du chapitre provisoire
qui allait être installé pendant les
travaux le temps qu'on reconstruit ce
magnifique équipement pour lequel la
région est engagée à hauteur de
40%. le projet de cette salle on finance
à la concurrence d'un million et demi
c'est-à-dire presque la moitié mais
surtout le renouvellement urbain à
Chanteloup on veut finance à hauteur
environ 53% l'équipement est aussi doté
d'une tribune télescopique permettant
d'accueillir 200 personnes en
configuration assise